[Music]
[Music]
hey
hey
i can see you right
drop the cheerios and no one gets
[Music]
hurt what is up guys mkbhd here and
you've heard of nest right they're a
company that's one of many that make a
home security camera i've been a nest
user for a couple of months so i have a
couple of their home security cameras i
have their thermostats and i have some
of their smoke detectors so obviously it
makes it easy to keep it all in one
place in one app
it's not perfect there are definitely
some minor annoyances but there are also
some really well thought out features to
it but now their newest cameras come out
and it's called the nest cam iq so shout
out to nest for sending a few of these
over to the studio and helping me make
this video it has a 4k sensor an updated
design and some new internals and a new
price tag so naturally the question is
is it worth it this little guy over here
it's 300 bucks and also a lot of its
best features go hand in hand with a
monthly subscription called the nest
aware subscription so it's definitely
not cheap so what exactly are you
getting with this thing well the design
first of all is pretty clean as you can
see the matte white look and there's
always the argument with a security
camera in an office with a lot of
obviously very expensive gear like this
do you hide the security camera out of
sight like up in a corner somewhere to
secretly get footage in case anything
happens and you need it or do you put it
like right in the doorway right in the
field of view so you know it's there to
discourage anything from happening in
the first place i chose the second
option as you can see it's been in
previous videos it's pointed right at
the doorway you walk in you know you're
on camera but at least it's not ugly so
a lot of security cameras are really
unattractive but you might have seen it
blend in in the background i'd consider
it a pretty modern two-tone panda design
it has that eve from wall-e type of look
it's got a swiveling head it connects to
power by usb type-c which is again
modern and you can mount it to the wall
pretty easily if you want to also so
this thing is pretty clean and then the
main headlining feature of nest iq is
the 4k sensor which actually needs some
explaining technically yes there is a
new 4k sensor inside the camera as well
as all the processing power and hardware
to support it
but it is not constantly recording 4k
security camera footage at all times
that would be a little insane it is
recording at all times in 1080p but
because it is a 4k sensor anytime you
want to zoom in up to four times on
anywhere in the frame you can do that
without losing any quality and it will
continue to be full 1080p even though
you've zoomed in without losing anything
that's the main benefit of having the
higher resolution sensor so then the
nest cam iq as you can probably tell by
the name is trying to be really smart
with all this new hardware so it has a
bunch of smart features to take
advantage of having this new 4k sensor
has facial recognition all this stuff so
the normal full field of view for the
camera is 130 degrees using the whole
sensor super wide angle as you can tell
looks like your normal security camera
footage but obviously really really
crisp and clear zoom in four times on
any part of the image and you can see it
keeps its quality a hundred percent it's
basically lossless zoom and then you can
keep zooming way in all the way to 12
times on the live feed if something's
really getting your attention and you
want to check it out now let's say
someone walks into the frame nest aware
recognizes faces and humans and will
sort of zoom in a bit and follow and
track that person around the frame as
they move it follows them around usually
with pretty decent success sometimes if
you move fast enough it can sort of lose
the subject but i've had no complaints
about this it makes sense to follow the
action and then those of you who are
familiar with nest will know about the
notifications already so i have mine set
to turn off whenever i get here and then
turn back on whenever i leave so if i'm
out and it detects some motion it'll
send a notification to my phone actually
with a little clip of what i just saw
which is pretty convenient the funny
thing is probably like 95 percent of the
time on the old nest cam probably like
99 of the time it's just like a random
sunlight change or a leaf blowing
outside of a window it would just send
notifications for random things that
weren't humans and i could set these uh
hot zones where it's specifically
monitoring that one zone but i just kind
of left it on and got a lot of spare
notifications but nest cam iq has been
really good for me about not sending me
all those spare notifications and just
notifying me when it sees unknown faces
or unknown humans in the frame because
it's using facial recognition it can
tell when it's a human and when it's
just a blob or something else that it
doesn't have to worry about and then on
top of that you can set what's called
familiar faces so instead of notifying
me about an unknown human every time it
sees something you can tell it to
remember certain faces so it knows and
can put in the notification if it's a
trusted person entering so that makes
perfect sense for a studio like this if
someone who works here walks in their
face is recognized and it notifies my
phone and has the person's name already
i don't have to worry about it the weird
thing is it doesn't let me turn on
notifications for unknown faces and turn
off notifications for known faces it
still notifies me every time a person
walks in but i'll know quicker if it's
someone unknown or not seems like a
pretty obvious thing i could add to the
software right if it's not a known face
i want to know if it's a known face i
don't really care but otherwise yeah
everything about this camera is better
than the previous version better
microphone array louder speakers for
talkback the camera itself is not
waterproof so it can't be your outdoor
cam uh but maybe able to make a 4k
version of that in the future overall
though this thing fits nicely into their
ecosystem of products so my consensus on
this little guy is it's really similar
obviously to previous nest cameras but a
little bit better in every way so if you
have a current nest camera you probably
don't need to upgrade you probably
haven't seen anything here that's going
to make you want to spend that money
however if you don't have any security
cameras you don't have a nest cam i kind
of highly recommend you get something
just to be safe and this kind of fits
itself nicely in the premium section of
that market for a lot of people
including myself who kind of value that
peace of mind i think it's worth it so
that's why i like them but that's pretty
much it let me know what you guys think
maybe you'd get one of these or
something else thank you for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you